policing is big business in Gretna I
came here because of an explosive piece
that called Gretna the arrests capital
of the United States 2/3 of those
arrested are black
while only 1/3 of the population is
black with those numbers
Gretna must be a really violent place
right actually of the 6566 arrests only
49 were for violent offenses that's less
than 1% fines fees and policing and
where have we seen that relationship
before look at how Ferguson Police
Department conducts their job the report
accuses police of targeting black and
poor drivers to raise revenue the city
relies on the police force to serve
essentially as a as a collection agency
in 2013 Ferguson took in two point four
six million dollars in court fines and
fees while Gretna in the same period
took in five point seven seven million
dollars so do black lives matter in
Gretna hell yeah
that's nearly fifteen percent of the
city's revenues five five five and that
proportion is sixteen times the national
media